depuis ce matin cette coiffeuse n'y
coupe pas face à un possible troisième
confinement le téléphone n'arrête pas de
sonner son carnet de rendez vous se
noircit ferme et déjà quatre mois l'an
passé nadège seul dans son salon
s'attend à devoir ranger prochainement
ses ciseaux avec une nouvelle perte de
revenu à laquelle il va falloir faire
face
on est toujours inquiet parce que bon
psychologiquement c'est difficile c'est
pas ma commerce qui nous fait vivre
néanmoins sur les premiers confinement
n'a pas été bien aidé et puis quand on
revient on est des commerces qui
retravaille tout de suite est beaucoup
mais fermer les magasins et une
troisième fois cela pourrait donner un
coup de massue aux commerçants les plus
fragiles une catastrophe économique à
venir selon le medef denis favier milite
avec son association pour que ces
commerces non essentiels puisse ouvrir
un peu leurs portes
nous travaillons avec bercy pour
proposer un confinement de demi journée
à savoir un matin ouvert pour tous les
commerces qu'ils ne soient essentielles
et non essentiels et une fermeture en
fin de matinée soit midi soit le mieux
serait un petit peu plus tard à 14
heures en plein soldes d'hiver prévus
jusqu'à mi-février certains s'inquiètent
aussi des stocks qui vont rester à
charge dans ce magasin de lingerie
on avait tous réadapté pour rassurer les
clientes et garder l'activité
on essaie de voilà de se rapprocher au
maximum d'elles et de leur montrer que
entre elles et nous il existe vraiment
un lien qui perdure quelle que soit
l'aide des événements en attendant les
dessous d'un troisième confinement ici
la fréquentation est en baisse mais les
achats en hausse
reste que conjuguer économie et
efficacité des mesures sanitaires sera
bien l'enjeu des prochaines décisions